what's up guys welcome back I'm Jim
Gettys this is nick Scarpino oh yeah the
illustrious Ryan Ryan ways yeah what's
up boys young man good man see you have
a good III oh yeah yeah welcome light
snow but start off right all right a
favorite thing III so far battlefront
hands down live far been waiting for it
so it's nice to see gameplay yeah so
yeah I enjoy battlefront the most it's
an good you know excited plays a Jedi's
I'm surprised I'm surprised if not more
people are talking about i think it's
because it's such a foregone conclusion
and it's gonna be a blast yeah i feel
like everyone saw it was like great
that's on point exactly how i will go
we're good point it's you might be right
i mean i was like awesome next game yeah
Oh player that's the I feel like fall
out uncharted in battlefield or
Battlefront I'll have that same feeling
of the site all right they're going to
be good and also it's like another call
duty another year I've got it man
upscale sports lack of course my asst
with my call duty yeah you got it you
got to put that right of the day yeah
why not do you try the the hollow hollow
lens no I haven't tried it but that was
amazing like yeah I've gotta get over
there get oh this is sweet I would it
there's like this video we there's this
halo demo that is just unbelievable it's
like you go in and then maybe I could
put the visor on you and it's like you
see the HUD come up and then they give
you a mission briefing before you do
like actually real halo and it's like
you're looking at a table and like the
the map comes up and it gives you like
coordinates and [ __ ] it's like this is
like better than Disney natal amazing
shoving it up man it's it's nuts but so
you're here for a very specific reason
yeah the tubes made some huge
announcements yes else a little bit of
that other than watching battlefront
game play and playing I'm here so yeah
like as YouTube has grown we've seen a
lot of different communities like beauty
fashion kids music gaming and so forth
and as you get bigger you kind of want
to have to you almost need to build out
specialized experiences because there's
no longer anything that you can build
for one that builds for everyone right
so that was kind of the spirit of
YouTube gaming we looked at the
landscape both on youtube and how things
are happening on the internet today
there's no one stop destination for all
VOD live content that's being created
and we needed a specialized experience
so that was YouTube gaming so in
addition to the app so it's a mobile app
tablet app and desktop experience is a
website as well
so you go to gaming youtube com and
check it out but in addition that we
launched a live product too so we felt
you know mission statement at YouTube is
to empower people to broadcast and share
we didn't have a good live platform so
if we kind of owed it to our fans and
creators have a really robust and kind
of state-of-the-art platform yeah so
we're rolling that out too that's that's
awesome so obviously there's gonna be a
lot of you know twitch right sure yeah
yeah embarrassing situation yeah how is
this dissimilar and how is this
different and what more does it have
yeah you know like I think what the
natural comparison it's like a google
amazon thing is to immediately gravitate
towards that you know we needed a live
platform can because we're a video
platform it just like doesn't make sense
to have like not have a live platform
for gaming news and so forth so you know
I think it's live is always gonna be a
smaller amount of watch time and then we
want to get into eSports one day and if
you want to get into eSports you have to
have a live platform like they're
inherently combine that it's it's it's
live competition so it was less about
that i mean we're actually still
supports which like if you're a twitch
streamer and you have a youtube channel
which like all of them do anyway when
you're live on twitch there's an
annotation that comes up on you two it's
like hey this channel is live on twitch
go check it out yeah so I think it's
probably a little bit more
sensationalized first you got to support
the gaming ecosystem to be honest you're
like the creators on YouTube will
succeed like when they're like Twitter
and Facebook and twitch and so forth
they get bigger on youtube so you kind
of want to support all of that yeah why
we link out socially to Twitter and
twitch and all these platform right yeah
how important is live though for you
guys right now because you hear news
stories I hear stories all the time for
like mainstream media television that
the revenues they're starting to go down
the only thing they can really sell hard
is live and for that matter sports you
always hear about like the Super Bowl
sells really really well but normal
network television is just not catching
on anymore obviously it's different for
you guys you're like live has to be a
big kind of push for you guys going
forward oh I think you know when you
look at yeah people are interested in
buying tentpole events and so forth
right behind you know like a like a big
III day or something like that right but
live if you look at like live watched I
mean if you look like twitches live
watch time it's it's small cuz its life
is like in the moment right like VOD is
always going to be the king there's a
lot of long tail there you can watch it
at your own leisure and so forth but you
have to have a live component because it
is that dangling carrot
for big events right again you can't
have a grade III you can't have a great
eSports tournament you can't have a
great podcast show if you don't have
live platform so it's more about it's
less about the monetization because I
don't see that as an issue like
advertising is great on YouTube right
it's more about like being able to
empower a creator to have the ability to
create different content in steps just
like doing VOD content and so forth they
can now do like another piece of its
kind of adding that last little bits the
toolset yeah exactly and you need it you
know I people we look at our top three
android gaming creators like eighty-five
percent of them are streaming anywhere
and it's like that it's a lot of know
not to go to another platform build that
audience drive that audience still
manage this platform so I think a lot of
them it's more about like I look at
who's on youtube today and who will
benefit from that yeah yeah I think it's
hun of creators will be like yeah I'm
gonna check live out and maybe lonely
shame like an hour two at a time and
make like nicely well produce live
videos like a podcast or something like
that that just goes up on VOD and so
forth yeah that's not so good so YouTube
live there's also the the gaming thing
yeah so what's that exactly called
YouTube gaming did you get we kept this
little man we can simply this is a big
deal this is the first time YouTube's
add another website and it is in to
youtube I feel like there's a lot of
confusion right now where people don't
understand if there are two separate
things if it's the same thing a lot of
people been asking if we're gonna have a
channel on YouTube gaming and I'm
telling them oh the same thing so how
does that work yeah I think I could have
probably better articulated that in
hindsight but yes YouTube gaming
basically takes all the gaming content
that's on youtube today and just allows
you to see it through a different lab
it's a hub yeah it's a lens and so
you'll still have like the way you
upload videos your channel all that's on
youtube com today won't change it all
you can still get gaming content on
YouTube core but now you can go into the
gaming app and you can see like game
pages and so forth so you can go into
you know destiny and then you can go in
and see the kind of funny videos if you
guys are doing destiny content and
counter strike and then there's live and
all the different concept that's
happening on top of that you still have
channel pages so you can kind of go to
like the game spot or kind of funny
channel through the app and then it's a
different way of looking at it so all of
your contents there as well so think of
it as like a lens to watch gaming
content for example you want to watch a
counter-strike video in the last 24
hours you get the search counter-strike
filter the search but 24 hours and then
kind of like cherry pick it based off a
keyword searching it's too hard for
discoverability so this
changes that it'll be good for small
craters around discoverability as well
that's exact same page as well yeah cool
so okay now going going back to live for
a second you know twitch has like a lot
of features that are missing from what
YouTube live is right now things like
yeah it's like a really robust chat are
we gonna see some of that Italy yeah
yeah so we have a 1080p 60 frames per
second we have html5 streaming which is
it's just time for everybody should be
on that that's a big thing we had to do
DVR so we're the only one thats DVRs you
can go into a broadcast if somebody was
like just got off work they haven't seen
anything you guys have done since the
start of this live show they can rewind
back and real way yes awesome yes so
like if someone was like I missed the
first two minutes of this interview is
they could just go back to it right
right now how does it make and then
chatting on boats and moderation doing
all that stuff more that's like that's
like bare bones man we gotta do we gotta
interview an asset good is there a way I
can ask for a feature request of when
they do that it does the bloop bloop
bloop from to up on the tivo do you
remember tivo tivo wow we should never
talk about every good i never mind but
it like as a p6 pilot yeah so recently
youtube moved to a new player or at
least it's in beta and stop flight how
does that factor into this at all what's
at the new YouTube player the new
YouTube liar now okay I don't know it's
beautiful yeah I'm a big fan of ya scrub
through it it's yeah right way nicer
than yeah yeah yeah so the VOD players
differ but yet think of it the same
concept for life yeah live streaming
that's not man that's really really at
all so something that this is a way more
personal thing about kind of funny that
I'm fairly interested in yeah is there
gonna be private live streams yeah you
can do private live streams today yeah
so you can do private unlisted and then
you know expose it normal yeah yeah and
then you know we're looking at different
things around subscription and stuff for
like oh yeah this is um I think this is
just like the tip of the iceberg of like
what we want to do I felt like I was
getting YouTube gaming out and a live
product two separate things we're
getting those out was like just getting
us where we needed to be previously the
next six to 12 months is going to be
even more fun because now we can
innovate like we're caught up right I
like now the race can begin I've like
getting cool products out for Yahoo
that's really cool yeah so are you
working with any gaming creators to kind
of like
make sure everything's right about this
and like to promote their content and
stuff like that yeah absolutely you know
we're focused on a wide group of
creators to get them live streaming and
you know offering it out there to them
because again our opportunity lies
within our own platforming the creators
that are on it and getting them live
streaming and uh it's really about
educating them because if you educate
them and they understand the opportunity
around discoverability and monetization
and so forth then they can make
well-informed calculated decisions on
how and when they should live but we
don't want to like get in them into like
you know exclusive contracts and do
stuff like that it's like empower them
to have a product if you want to use it
great if not thats that's good to let us
know why you're not so we can make it
better that's awesome yeah my question
is how do we make these two phases the
phases of a youtube game that's fine
just come over the booth will take a
picture we'll just use that for all of
our thumbnails for all of our marketing
assets everything's gonna be really good
done beard was made for thumbnails yeah
look when you drink it down my face was
not man share some of that you really
ask you know in my way problem with the
beard is nope still it comes with hair
everywhere yeah you're just having here
you gotta you gotta take the good with
the bad fair enough I'm talking about
back here Oh alive you gotta get that
wet wax top every couple weeks well you
know I'm to chief of that so I just have
no modern j-pop Onan you know keeps me
warm during the winter out good there
you go yeah man so what I mean overall
this this is not your first III you've
been to multiple yeah my favorite III
know it has to be my one of my favorite
ethers yeah let's Segway away from
gaming prob yeah we'll come back to that
second but it's weird to watch this show
sort of evolved because back in the how
long have you what was the first thing
this is my fifth fifth okay so you might
have caught the craziness of it no you
cut you may have came it did you coming
when it was like the Hang Ten yeah I
remember when it was freaking nuts this
I think is the right like vibe destroyed
oh it's nice to go there strife are you
gonna are you have a lot of appointments
for us today are you gonna go out and
play some nice no it's been it's it's
been really shitty in that regard
because like all I've done has just been
meeting with people and doing like price
interviews and have not got to play
games yeah cuz the nice thing was always
having the exhibitor badge coming at
nine queuing up get it in there and then
a fashionable Tayside media so you just
will excuse me it's play games like now
I haven't got to play anything
I think that's way battle from the only
game I want to play oh you got to get
over there no I am like literally
yuckies wherever that issue too we're
having fun here talking I know on the
internet but it's like there's video
games everywhere oh you guys have
probably you as we're always playing
video games doing like firsthand looks
for your exact yeah it's like it's like
a nice oh it's definitely it's a little
different but you know it's but it's
been fun though and obviously for me
it's been such a unique experience like
lunch and then have YouTube here for the
first time and then you know work with
Jeff and rooster teeth and all that it's
been it's been really cool man tell me
one of the more memorable ones those
guys are crazy by the way they are
currency yeah how's the been working
with roosterteeth they're crazy man yeah
yeah it's good it's good i've known
berman for a really long time now so i
was fun to uh it's always fun to team up
with him on stuff in your weight there
and then it remind me how you you guys
provided the stage and they're doing all
the program yeah yeah so they're on
there the programming out of on rooster
teeth's channel right before but we're
going to youtube.com slash III is our
destination so like all the stuffs on
there and then we're bringing like take
20 different creators have come on in
the show so including us including a
room will be there shortly gross yeah so
early we wanted like day one to feel
very well you know like professional
produce it's why he put like mr. Ryan
Seacrest Jeff Kelly on there and then
you wanted it to be like the spirit of
YouTube which is like roosterteeth and
our creators like what drives it so I
felt like we were able to knock about
balance yeah yeah definitely it's nice i
haven't even seen Ryan yet I think I
think we saw him run try to get in they
forgot his badge and they literally
chased him down there being crazy and
they took him out he's of course he's
like do you not know who I am I bull you
pulled the famous line that I didn't
hear that but that's what I imagined in
my brain he pulls that even at starbucks
yeah I would I try feel that [ __ ] at
starbucks yeah you guys see that they
look like yesterday added this thing
where you can use the app to order ahead
of time as you can just go in ok and
order you go in just pick it up changer
I think we're going to be stealing
coffees now I'm gonna go are you one of
those guys on you look at even bother
checking the name I'm like Jackson works
lookups not even close to Ryan yeah man
so are you is your last day are you
thank you that's a follow up I'm going
like an 18-hour coma
yeah it's been brutal man yeah my god is
this the first III that YouTube has
actually screamed for right this is the
first so we've had press conferences on
YouTube previously we're like Xbox to
put them on and PlayStation and they
were on youtube and then you know people
watch them there but this is the first
one like where we saw huge viewership
and that we got behind it youtube and
actually put resources into it first
time here at a booth so yeah it was uh
it was like way over do you know it's
like we should have been doing the [ __ ]
yeah so I'm glad that we're doing it now
man yeah it's been cool the last couple
conventions I venture like taxes and
stuff like that there's been a YouTube
booth and that's been really cool to see
that people that they are bit youtube
understand YouTube gets it yeah I mean
it's undisputable that it is the best
video platform so it's like people get
that and to see youtube understand the
gaming is a huge part of that that's
great you know help you guys are doing
good [ __ ] now the big question for you
though is did you get to see Kanye West
yesterday we were giving live update
reports all day yeah Kanye was
apparently in the building Kim was not
here I saw kanye I tickled him and I
made him laugh did you really no I took
a little meeting which I was half true
yeah that happened he just gotta had his
hoe down and kept drinking the sugar
fever yeah it was cool Kanye West was
here in the building that's a fact yeah
Chet was out definitely where everyone
out that it doesn't think gaming is
mainstream Kanye West says that it is
it's not Tom Arnold and kanye west is an
al-qaeda spectrum right there tomorrow
really is yes we're somewhere in the
middle of it I guess we're more probably
Kanye West okay imma go Kanye I'm gonna
go Kanye is you love Mikhail's army but
yes maybe I don't know it doesn't matter
um yeah man Jesus my brain is dead let's
say how you guys every day free I don't
know what I let's go let's go back we're
going back to the games oh my god like
so besides Star Wars is there anything
else that you looking forward to right
now no man's sky when yeah yeah yeah so
no man's sky is really interesting
because it's like we've seen these demos
and it looks amazing then you're like
where's the game yeah yeah that's what
made me laugh cuz I'm like the pure
epicness of just being able to go
anywhere and all these different plants
in the galaxy but then yeah during the
demo he went there and I was like all
right soon all right you're collecting
resources and put like what like what's
going on like Google
calyx for you let me tell you why okay
go to break this down get down what no
man skies all da hah do you remember
there's a little game called mass effect
that yeah yes then it's a little game
called mastic to that came out it yeah I
mean mass spec to everyone thought it
was about the plot right right are these
like these I thought Jessica Chobot but
yeah it's always my Jessica Java every
spoil everything everything always
especially she's in within a 400 foot
radius of me there's got to be about
Jess speaking of which she literally
never ages I saw her the other day I'm
like I don't know what are you 16 does
she think she is yeah um I think she
have it on good authority that she
actually kills virgins just as well to
[ __ ] forever when she works early i
didn't say buddy you know why i left
with joe bar to watch oh yeah well
afraid it was good but yeah i'm a little
screwed up but in mass effect you going
back to that everyone thought it was
about the story at all this great
character at all and it was it the real
gameplay with scanning planets okay i
did that for hours and here's why no
competition it's like the yoga of video
games right you're not competing with
anything you're not try to achieve
anything you're just relaxing and
exploring yourself right it's just for
you so this game just killing so now
hate people to get stoned and just like
fly right now your baby I'm just gonna
hit it real hard and then like motor
great and they just scan planets all day
it's and there's no game show every why
do we need to achieve [ __ ] in gaming why
don't we just decide to hard cuz get
we're elitist right yeah you have any
idea how many planets are gonna be named
after penises like it's gonna be amazing
if you get you get to name the planet
when you get that think you do do you
not I'm gonna task my baby yo baby just
go to planets and put my name down here
you know I God was one was our yeah yeah
that's what they should do because I
think they went to the demo no like this
is a discipline I've never seen it was
like ooh babe ol number one or whatever
it was they should let you name planets
but yeah it's a good idea so what's
interesting though it'll start charging
five dollars oh my god i have a theme
park on your planet I would have a
galaxy oh yeah I feel lousy good so
we've seen these demos it's all these
press conferences of no man's sky and it
always looks pretty similar but I
remember the first time I thought I was
like this is incredible but then now
we're kind of just used to it and it's
all right but yesterday we're here and
up on this big ridiculous screen that's
right happening above us there's a game
playing and a bunch of people who were
saying we're like what is this
it was like the snowy planet and there
was like these huge ships and stuff like
what game is this and everyone started
rumbling like is that no man's sky I
think that's no man's sky no that's not
oh my god it's no man's sky I'd it was
one of those moments where I was like
they should have shown this in the demo
because I know it showed that like there
are so many varied planets and that the
experience is not just hey here's this
empty planet there is something about
how amazing that is is he pulled back in
that demo like I kept going back and
like literally yeah like is a son and a
planet and like galaxy and it's like
that's wild yeah everywhere definitely
go on youtube and search for no man's
sky i defined III 2015 and find new the
new videos because it's incredible it
could i'm like 'oh looking up watching
battlefront sorry it could it could have
like a minecraft complex to achieve if
there is some fun stopping like people
going in a planet yeah right I can see
it son of YouTube videos about planets
being explored yeah okay I can go down
that route as a potential to do so
something interesting about that game is
we have no idea when it's coming like
yeah well I at least get a little tease
yeah but what's cool that we talked to
colin a lot about this but like that
game so unique in the way that it could
be a 2015 game 2016 Rio 17 we don't know
it or not so vast it's so weird that
like it could come out tomorrow or it
could never come out you know he say
something I thought like he's like a
release date is coming too so where the
hell that means yeah oh and oh sorry
Simon never what is wrong Halloween all
thousand seven bit dead before half
these games they announced come out oh
yeah like final fantasy 7 HD will see
that never yeah yeah but your kid this
one job yeah keep doing little teasers
for the next ten years it'll yeah that's
true don't bring it back and you know
you big I did you have you played do you
play final fantasy last time played
final fantasy I was like 12 and it was
seven yeah whatever that was forever ago
that was that yeah yeah that was about
me too i wasn't in place I'm like a
little ADHD it doesn't like flow with my
mazda style yeah yeah give you that co d
well which no I'm not like that much
we're like a crackhead but somewhere
between final fantasy in that yeah so
we're between Final Fantasy I'd call of
Jay yeah yeah that's I think that's
everything everything has really LOL
kanye west's haha wait which one would
be more tom arnold which one would be
more Kanye oh I think Kanye is probably
more call duty really say that
on his final fantasy have you seen the
way you dresses that's true no way yeah
address yeah but alright so those
shutters the easies though you know that
dude dad we gotta get a pair of those
yeah i'm sure those what are those let's
look amazingly i don't even know just
some nikes man i don't know man they
look like half nike how sock there are
charged I think honestly I'm sure like
that was how they came up with this
concept to like you know what people
don't need socks anymore we came in the
mornings like chuck it shoes socks we
make it a shoe boom yeah boom Oh pay
this man hey this hahaha that's how you
move up the executive ladder at Nike
basic ya say you move the exact ladder
at kind of funny honey I had great ideas
do when we get rewarded yeah exactly
rightfully so so what's your game of the
show so far this is dr. outside of a I
really do have to go down from just
because like I'm a huge Star Wars fan
yeah I'm really all over the Star Wars
hype train 47 know like you know so and
I've been waiting for this game for a
while yeah I thought it was really cool
how they did the the release of the
trailer and then the release of the like
the video game rendering version of it I
I just could see like that's what's
gonna take up the most amount of time
yeah obviously fallout 4 but like we're
gonna have to we're all gonna have to
make tough decisions in November as
games it's gonna be crazy now well my
decision is not staying the hell away
from fallout 4 yeah I can i yeah it was
just play dude yeah I can't do it I
can't do it um I'm like 100 son taking a
week off in november just play video
games huh oh that's great yes Martin
yeah yeah my theory with battlefront is
that like it's one of the we've seen
before why didn't they show the show
last year well what are those in
gameplay they should trim units going
songwriter right and was like my way
solenoid no way it's gonna look like oh
then they show at uh was that EA was the
hoff level what was that yeah there was
a teaser with ha two years ago no no but
they showed that the first they showed
two demos it was end or what it was a
rendering of a night that was rendering
in like the last one the wall I've got
it yeah and we did it awesome hot on
time oh yeah and you're like no way
anybody goes out of the ice tunnel and
you start hearing that it's really the
blasters yeah the sound of 8080 blaster
let's high five it just literally goes
like this it takes me from a 35 year old
man with a lot of hair on his body to it
like a ten-year-old kid with a little
less
yeah and it's just I don't know is it
ever gonna get tiring like you know they
were gonna get old the idea that you
have like battlefield in Star Wars where
it's like I can have my buddies and like
an x-wing flying around that's good I'm
like on the ground is like a Jedi yeah
you got stormtroopers on the other side
and it's like how fun is that gonna be
what soap that trailer that ended with
Luke with Vader just life's bad ass oh
my god man that gave no good to be my
biggest problem is the last time I play
battlefront I would didn't know what I
was doing and I got stuck being a wookie
for like 35 minutes while my buddy
Brennan are you my good friend Brenner
you was like always Yoda just flying
around the map and I'm like how do i get
to be always like you gotta be better
bro yeah better i'm like so chewy man
that sucks that's the last time i was on
balfour wha PSP yeah i went in on that
guy alrighty alrighty alright yeah since
in greg's of a PSP guys really you guys
drank the PSP kool-aid heavy mayo yeah
the old republic yeah like I played the
old republic for a while they showed the
the Knights love two brothers with oh
yeah oh my god they always make sweet
cgi videos is it is it a blur blur again
yeah it's like I same guy they made the
tree I didn't have to a big idea right
yeah those make a move I might come back
and pull up my character for that as
well they let's for [ __ ] you watch that
trailer and you're like why do they not
just give these guys 50 million dollars
make a movie go make a movie I've been
saying that for the last five years that
was that was like by far the most
compelling yeah I've seen like animation
you're talking about a two minute
trailer that has like more heart than
their last three movies well true and
it's a brother's conflicted man no good
so well done so beautifully paying don't
wrap it up here all right what is your
final words about YouTube loss youtube
gaming all this stuff we find me on the
internet have a one-stop destination for
all gaming content both live and VOD bam
bear did it let's say we did it that's
it that's great i love it man that's
awesome i throw the busway get some
ready never just did a hell of a job to
sleep when we're dead we have a man to
that yeah due to manager sage looks
great soup out of the backside of the
god oh yeah seeing you guys later yeah
but when thank you so much for coming so
haven't miss you so fun always we're
gonna we're gonna bump to a quick break
we'll be right back thank you thank you
so much okay said 10 seconds I wrapped
it up a little early sketches on Kevin
just run camp kind of funny